It was close to a perfect night for the crowd
at the Lexington bar in Islington.
Here, in the north London constituency of
Labour leader, Jeremy Corbyn, many had just
a glimmer of hope when the exit polls started
to trickle in.
The mood soon changed.
"Positive!"
"Magnificent."
"Wonderful!"
"I'm feeling very pleased. Anything is better than a Tory majority."
A hung parliament isn't ideal but then I'm
just happy that Labour are making some gains."
"It's disappointing to me, you could imagine
what would have happened if Labour had actually
supported Jeremy Corbyn a lot earlier.
Then we might have seen quite a substantial
Labour lead."
Meanwhile, the business of counting ballots
got underway.
Each vote checked by hand – like here in
Lambeth, a south London district.
And campaigners on the sidelines were already
taking stock.
"It looks as though Theresa May has made a
bit of a blunder really in calling this election.
I'm not entirely sure how she is getting on
with the rest of her party"
"It has not been a brilliant night for us.
I think our campaign could have been better,
I think everyone acknowledges that within
the party.
I think we could have talked more about the
things that we have done well over the past
seven years."
Back at The Lexington bar in Islington – cheering
and celebrations continued into the early
hours.
For these Labour supporters at least, it's
a vote to remember.